Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to Riddle School 4.
The next one in the series,
and I'm certain...
If I know anything about these games,
I'm going to be escaping...
...from some sort of school.
For some sort of reason.
But now that I know that there's...
Oh?
A possibility of some darker themes going on here,
I'm curious as to what the hell is happening here.
Is this going to be...
... a digital school?
Is this parodying online schools?
Is this Phoenix University?
Oh, it's so much better!
Oh, it's nice.
I like this a lot.
Oh...
*click*
*person screaming*
Uhhhh... Excuuuuse me?
*intense scream*
*crash* I--ha--hu...don't know...
Uhhh...
I have a lot of questions here.
Why did that teacher have a ready-access button
that lead to a portal to hell?
"Phil's teacher, Mr. Munch, was the original architect of Riddle University."
"The school was built above a long pit of lava that he himself dug near an active underwater volcano."
See, this is what I appreciate:
I ask a question...
The game immediately answers it.
"His plan to murder Phil Eggtree, to forever rid him of this world, succeeded."
And, uh, the mystery is solved,
And there goes the series.
Thank you, everyone, so much for joining us.
I really do appreciate each and every one of you...
Let me know what you thought of this...
Oh.
"Every other student of Riddle University eventually died, from car wrecks, old age, and unforeseen divasters."
"Each one, on their death bed, whispered their final wish:"
"Please... don't let there be any more Riddle School games."
Hm.
Hmm...
"Stay tuned after the credits to see your time."
Well, there you have it.
Once again, I wanna say about the impeccable quality of this game.
I really did like...
uh, the intricate levels and the design of the school this time.
Because, it was super weird.
It was like a hyper cube;
It was four-dimensional in a way.
You got to go in rooms inside of rooms, that led to other rooms.
Now I don't know how I figured it all out.
It must be that I'm a super genius or something.
Me and JonBro, we're on the same level over here
when it comes to making these levels and making these games.
Uhh... Super awesome experience.
The--having a full orchestra actually play, uh, in the middle of the game was ridiculously cool,
I loved that a lot.
It was superb...
uh, in every aspect of the way. And, uh, might I say the graphics, like photo-realistic isn't even a word that
could appropriately described the beauty that I th-- that I saw.
It was like, peering... into... the heavens above.
It was like staring into the most beautiful thing in the world, and that literally just blinds you from it's glory.
I cannot fathom, how he could possibly follow this game up with another one. BUT!
We'll get to that game real soon, just as soon as I... recover from this.
I'm gonna need, like, a 3 week vacation to emotionally deal with what just happened in front of us.
So, either way...
Thank you guys so much for watching!
And as always, I will see you... in the next video.
Buh!--
Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome to Riddle School 5!
Now, for some reason, there is no Riddle School 4
What??
No, I don't know--
What?
No.
What're you talking about? This is the start of the video. We haven't done anything before this
I dunno what you're...
You--you need me to do the intro? I'll do the intro again.
*Whhaapsshhhh* TOP O' THE MORNIN' TO YA LADDIES!
*gag*
So welcome to Riddle School 5, Riddle School 4 was an April Fools' joke.
HAHAHA AH ha ha ha ha ha aw...
But now this is a real one so...
Welcome to Riddle School 5.
Now, we all know how, incredible, Riddle School 4 was so it'll be hard to top
"WELL, everyone, it seems soon our dreams will become... reality..."
BAM!
"...just as all of our prisoners' realities have become dreams."
"We all know our prisoners were taken from Riddle Elementary School."
"Enlighten our listeners as to the reason we're here already"
"I was getting to that part, Viz"
"This meeting is primarily to discuss these human suspects and their new dreams."
"Their behavior, after all, is why and how we are going through with our plan."
"Yes, because evildoers do deserve nothing more than the taste of their own evil"
Eughh...
This is Phred...
We can read the caption
"I'm enlightening everyone, just like you said"
"Phred in his dreams does as close to nothing as he can imagine"
"Of the prisoners we have, he seems to be the least useful right now."
Smiley...
"Smiley smiles constantly within her dreams"
"We've tried to find intended flaws in her ways, not yet to any avail."
"If one human is proven to be scum, the rest are no cleaner."
"Her face is nothing but a cover for her ugly desires."
"Zack here was shivering long before he was abducted from that school."
"It seems impossible that he would be so ongoingly chilly."
"There's a chance that by looking into his unusual condition..."
"...we could power a weapon capable of freezing that pathetic planet Earth."
"Hm, I could've sworn I was the one telling the presentation."
"And here we have the reason for our master plan."
"Had we not witnessed firsthand Phil escaping from his own school..."
"...Earth would not have become our first target of destruction."
"We can get into his brain, but what matters most is what we try to get out of it."
"knowing the enemy's the best way to defeat them."
"Uh, Diz?  I can't remember what the plan is, exactly."
"Quiz you're completely useless."
"Well, I can clarify"
"with the knowledge we receive from these three dream captives..."
"It's planned we completely freeze their home world, planet earth."
"This procedure is to be repeated to other wrongdoing planets."
"I have one more question."
"Go ahead, Quiz."
"When you were talking just a second ago,
"You said 'from the knowledge we receive from these three dream captives.' "
"Didn't you mean to say four?"
"Of course, just a slip of the tongue."
"Hey, why isn't the transmitter turned off? What if one of our subjects hears?
"Sorry, didn't even know it was on."
"It'll be turned off in a seco--"
Oaah.
Oh!
It was all a dream.
We were never in that school.
Thats why that school didn't make any sense.
Oh hi!
Welcome...
...to the real world.
HOT-DIGGITY!
Oh shit!
We're not gonna be escaping from the school this time.
Are we?
Oooooooooooh~ TITTIES!
oooOOOhoho
Yea...
Anything in there?
"If this wasnt screwed to the wall then i could move this cover and move over"
Alrighty then.
Under the bed?
Ah, an alien coin!
Oh okay, so we're still collecting coins here.
Alright, lightbulb.
Anything, anything, anything?
Can't open that, "Remote activated from the other side."
So, maybe I can use the coin...
I can indeed do that!
And it's so well animated too.
What a functional coin.
Take these skwoose.
I put the skwoo in da tuna.
Hello!
"ive decided I don't want to do that again."
Umm... Okay.
"There's a button on this duck statue
but it doesn't seem to do anything."
Okay...
Oh, it's one of these puzzles.
Well good thing I'm really good- Oh...
I have to get a certain pattern that's listed below.
That's gonna be more difficult, im not 100% sure about my ability to do that...
Ohh~
Titties
Oh no.
Oh no, oh God damn it, I was close.
Oh, I got one!!
Hey! I got one of 'em.
I guess if you just flail wildly, eventually you'll get all of 'em, right?
Maybe?
Probably not.
That's not how this works, is it?
Anyway there we go, got another!
Took long enough.
'Kay.
Doodle'eh; doodle'eh, doodle'eh.
Doodle'eh!
Ah, there we go!
I got it all.
Ohhh! Ohh, it was just numbers!?
Oh I didnt have to do that! 4701!
I could have done that anytime.
"Whoa, out of sight, out of mind."?
OOOOOOooooh...
Nice; am I, is that permanent? no its not...
Hi Smiley, how you doin'?
Well that was stupid of you, why did ya do that?
"I really hope there's a better way to wake up my friends."
Yeah, that didnt work at all. That's not even a way.
Flower room?
Aaaah...
Hello! thank you for you!
"This plant's not immediately dying, so I'll take it."
Yeah, that seems like a logical thing to do.
Why not take it?
Moose picture.
Tray.
Random picture.
Tour.
Mute.
Weird sun...
...Apparently.
'Kay.
So.
Ah, keycard.
Why would they just leave a keycard in Phred's room here?
Why are you still doing that!?
You're still dumb.
Don't do that!
Even though I'm the one that make you click on that
So you can't exactly look at me and make that happen.
But... it's okay.
4, 7... Hi!
"Kinda cute"
Okay, so why isn't it doing anything about me?
Hello.
So... escape pods, huh?
Alright, so we've gotta get out friends first, that's number one...
Oh..!
"A room that has a pit of acid"
That's lovely,
thank you for that... vital information.
I'll take that car when I...
...Forget completely about that and fall right in.
Okay...
What about four? Ehehehe...
Okay.
So what's on the ceiling?
Besides what I... It's ectoplasm!
Eh, there's ectoplasm on the ceiling.
That's weird.
Okay...
Huh...
Life... wait; life-transferring station.
"Living thing goes here", "Dead animal goes here".
Well that doesn't seem like... it... it's just a Kill-O-Matic.
It...
The... this thing just murders people.
"To properly transfer life from a living thing to a dead animal
it's as easy as, 1-2-3:"
"(Also, know that the living thing dies when
the dead animal comes to life)"
Oh!
I thought it was like a conveyor belt.
Put a living animal in this side!
Magically it's dead on the other one!
Congratulations! you've killed it.
Alright so, I have something living here.
But I need something dead.
Probably something that I wanna bring back to life
or maybe...
Um... maybe just bring it to life in general.
"Oh, I almost forgot!" Oh wait...
This one.
"Remember to feed Oswald (the monster)
- he only eats life meat!"
Nit Wit.
"Oh, I almost forgot! He doesn't eat what he can't smell.
So find food with an aroma
and put it where smell can easily spread."
Huh.
Well... there's food up here that I can get.
So there's gotta be something that I can combine here.
Some kind of keycard that I can use.
Oh.
Well that's handy.
Heh-boink.
Wait... but that was my room.
Why did I need to come right back into my room?
Why did I need to do that? Oh...
I think I know why; because I need to lock it in there.
Ahh... Okay...
I got it.
Okay, so this is gonna hide me.
Until I need to go.
That makes a lot of sense, okay.
Ah, another screw, okay, so...
Oh, I know what that's for.
Okay, so I need to look under the beds
of all the other subjects.
That's what I need to do.
"I see a tissue, obviously used, no way I'm using that" Okay.
That's weird.
This bed.
"I see a photo of a puking gorilla under the bed
It doesn't quite tickle my fancy.
Okay, so the only thing that I got was a screw.
Oh, power.
Okay.
So, there's no power..?
Oh, but I have screws!
Oh, that makes sense.
Okay, now that's why I need four.
Got it! Oh that's pretty.
Oh that's real pretty there.
So... why are the gauges lizards?
Those gauges are lizards, right? That's...
That's not just me, right?
It's... it's definitely a thing.
Okay, so I need a...
Now I need a dead animal.
What am I gonna do for that?
Ahhh!
Ohhh!
It was a hidden door!
Yeah!
Okay...
Okay... Alright...
Okay... Alright... Okay...
Okay...
Alright.
Okay.
Ahhh... On the minimap, you can see...
...There's a tiny, itty bitty gap in between this room and the next one.
Ah, I don't know why I didn't notice that before
considering I saw the hidden door.
I just didn't connect the dots that there was any
possibility that that could be what that was.
So... I belive that I need to put this in here somewhere.
Oh no, I need to, oh, I need to, oh, I gotta...
I think I have to give this meat life.
Ooo, I don't know if this is... I don't know if this is morally good.
Urrr...
Was it though?
"I think there's a reason the meat didn't survive
with the plant's life."
Urr, ohh...
Well that's convenient.
I... didn't know about that, I don't know what you're talking about.
Is it? Oh...
Is it gonna, it's gonna, oh...
Eww
Well that doesn't make any sense at all!
"It's, uh, adorable."
That is a reach, the only reason I got that
is because I was clicking absolutely everything
to absolutely everything.
Which is like my last ditch resort on puzzle games.
And I filled the tray with dirt.
I mean, I get where you're going for there
but, Mmmm... okay, alright, so...
Now I've got...
What amounts to a living steak.
For some reason with plant legs.
That I have to... I imagine I have to place it in here somewhere.
But where?
Maybe I gotta... Ohhh..!
Of course.
So... if I hide by... Yeah! Go get it buddy boo.
'Kay, he's gonna go in there and then I lock him back in.
Bam! Okay, so I got him out of the way!
Man, that was a big of a stretch I will readily admit.
'Kay, hello.
Ah, I shouldn't be in here, my brain's not able to comprehend everything in here.
"Enter the children's dreams"
"It was" Ahh...
"I could be wrong, but this looks important."
"Enter" Ahh, I'm tryin' to read it.
"Enter the children's dreams in the chair in the next room..."
"...Their dreams will only end when in them, they meet doom."
"Something's clicking in my head."
I died! Oh...
"My friends are physically protected by barriers."
"Because of this I can't directly wake them up"
"However..."
Ahhh...
"...My dream that went on into college stopped when I was killed"
"...Their dreams will only end when in them, they meet doom."
"Which means..."
I gotta kill my friends!
Yeah!!!
Woo!!!
Killing friends, party time! Aw yeah, okay...
I probably shouldn't be shouting that at the top of my lungs.
Well let's go in here.
4701, what that it? Boinkety boink.
Well hang on; this was a key... this was a code.
4701, that was the code, okay but I just... I've gotta go...
...Get each of these; 7272...
...1831.
Okay.
7-2-7-2.
Whry, whry, wrhy...
...whrey, whry, whei...
...whay, whay, whay, whay...
...whoa, whee, whoa, whee, whoa, whee, whoa, whee, whoa-
I like to think that I enhance... the games that I play with.
Clever commentary.
You know what I mean?
So now it all makes sense
why it was entering The Matrix
in here, in Riddle School 4.
It was... there all along.
Incredible.
Who would have known?
Who would have known... Oh it's even in the style!
"Nobody's here, I think class hasn't started yet."
"Wait a minute,"
Uh oh...
"Phred never has a seat in this room, so how is this his dream?"
"Hey Phil?"
Hi.
"Is this Mr. McMaster's Room?"
Yes it is...
...Indeed it is, here's your seat.
Oh hell yeah.
Yeah! Okay, he's on the right train of thought!
Okay.
"I didn't get killed or something."
Alright... cool.
Oh yeah.
It's a...
Hell yeah.
Oh yeah.
So, now...
Hey Phred.
Let's see. "Would you like to wear my sweatshirt?"
Oh yeah, 'cause in the other one, I remember that! It said that it was
green!
*Sigh*
Oh man, I remember that.
Oh yeah...
Oh...
Ummm.
Uuuh...
Sorry, I'm not reading this! Why am I not-
I'm just enjoying myself... "You forgot to wake up this morning."
Okay, "you have to die."
"You only wore your underwear"
Let's see, "What are your future career plans?"
"I'll stop talking now, goodbye."
"I don't have loads of time, so why would I leave the room?" Well I don't know.
"Description of Phil" Well I gotta edit this.
"Looks like this" "Needs to sit in that desk".
Man... It is connected, it is...
Huh, I need...
...I need...
Oh..! Now he's gonna want it.
"Room is relatively cold."
"Hey Phred? Would you like my sweatshirt?"
There you go.
Ohhh... It's perfect.
It's perfect.
I love it.
Mister Munch.
Good job Mr. Munch, Phred is now dead.
Welp, that is so sa... it all connects!
It does connect.
Arrrrgh!
And he'd dead.
Okay, so 1831 was the next one.
18-31.
I'm not gonna add sound effect to this one
because I don't feel like it's necessary
to enhance the experience!
You guys know what's going on.
Right..?
Maybe.
Oh... It's a different room.
Oh, this is from a different riddle school.
Ohhh...
It's Riddle School 3..! Oh shit, we're going back in time,
this is so cool.
Aw, it's in the style too.
"Ah, the familiar Mr. Soggy's class from my dream.
"If possible I'm gonna kill Smiley quickly and painlessly.
But it's probably not gonna do that.
Probably gonna be slow and...
...Deadly...
Hey.
Okay.
"She doesn't have a clue what I'm trying to do."
So if I remember.
I have to get...
...The gum off... yep, the gum.
Stick that here.
For some reason, get a rubber band, and no one notices that this happens.
Totally fine..!
My God, it's the same... it's so cool.
And... now I'm gonna...
I'm gonna smack you with the rubber band
until you die.
Okay...
Do I gotta do this to Mr. Soggy again?
Wubing!
And... shubam.
Okay so... how do I kill you!?
Oh, this is so he doesn't see the murder.
"Oh no, Soggy's glasses fell on the floor.
"It sure is too bad he can't teach without 'em on."
Awww, Smiley frowned.
Ah oh... Urr.
Smiley? Oh no... Oh no!
Oh no..!
Oh, no...
Oh geez, oh God.
*Laughter*
Oh, that was amazing.
Oh, I love that.
Okay, I've gotta check the other...
6553... Oh man, that was hilarious.
Oh man, I loved that.
I don't know why I'm saying I love that.
Just witnessed a murder in this game
but man! If there's something that I enjoy...
Woo boy, it was what I just saw.
Oh man.
That was hilarious.
Ah is this gonna be riddle school 1 or 2?
I bet it's gonna be 2.
Considering 1...
...Was so long ago.
Oh no it is! Is it? No it's not.
Ah, it's 2.
It's 2, it's 2 indeed it is 2.
Alrighty then, hello..! Hi...
Get ready Zack, you're about to... meet your maker.
"I'd like to kill Zack fast, so I don't have to repeat the 7th grade."
Meh, you could sound more morbid.
Do I need these quarters?
Is there one in the quarter notes? Nope there's not.
Too hilarious.
Ummm... Zack..?
Urrr... Oh.
Okay...
...Do I need to- Oh 'kay I do need to do that.
Oh God...
Oh no.
Do I have to just hammer him?
He's frozen.
Oh no.
Oh no!
I guess it's not as bad as... Inhaling entire globe!
Okay, so now I got 'em all.
And apparently I'm gonna be able to go rescue 'em,
Correct? yes.
Hello..!
"You're awake."
"I thought I died because suddenly I felt cold..."
Okay.
Oh.
Goodbye!
Urr, I don't know how we're gonna stop him from destroying the Earth.
But, y'know, at least it's a good start.
Hi Smiley.
"All I can say is I just woke up from a really long dream."
"Oh yeah, we're also not on Earth anymore
but that can be fixed there's escape pods!"
"Guess I'll see you on Earth!"
Yeah that's... You're taking this in stride at least.
I guess.
Alright, hey Phred.
Hi..?
"I don't know what's going on, do you?"
Uhh yeah... Escape pods...
...Slowly, they gonna destroy the Earth...
...Oh yada, yada, yada, okay, we're done.
Alright, so now it's time for me to go, right?
I get to join my friends maybe? Maybe?
*Gasp*
I have escaped...
...I have escaped...
...I have escaped..! Oh 'kay, no I haven't.
Welp, this doesn't seem like what I was hoping for.
Where am I going?
Another alien?
A more different alien species.
Well...
Okay the- Oh, they've got gooby gabbers.
Oh! Awww...
Well this didn't go as planned.
Oh no... Oh no!
They're gonna use his cold power to freeze the Earth.
"Marvelous, isn't it?"
Oh, hi, Oh...
Very sinister, I like it a lot, that's a good touch,
you keep that up man, you keep that up.
"I am Viz; decider of your world's fate."
"Uh, nice to meet you."
"What's going on here?"
"Why don't you ask that cowardly traitor over there?"
Oh hi.
Oh, you're welcome. "I'll be taking this, thank you."
Okay goodbye!
"So cowardly traitor, what exactly is going on here?"
"I'm a traitor, but not to you."
"My name is Diz."
"Diz, I recognise that name, and Viz too."
"Weren't you in that meeting in the transmission before I woke from the dream?"
"You said you were planning to freeze planet Earth."
"None of this will make sense unless I start from the very beginning."
"It began, with Vizion."
"Vizion was a project started by our leader, Viz; the one you just saw."
"He felt it was his duty to decide the fate of every planet in the universe."
"His planet-by-planet journey began with your planet, Earth."
"Nobody was in agreement with his plan, of course, but we were under his rule."
"He gave his minions one chance to prove Earth wasn't worth erasing."
"We built a local time-stopping mine and set it outside of an Earth school."
"As it would turn out, the school was Riddle elementary School, where you were."
"Our hope was that nobody would escape the school."
"Unfortunately that day, was the very same day you left school early."
"Time throughout Earth stopped and Viz was convinced Earth has evil intent."
"He ordered us to abduct you and your friends before restoring Earth's time."
"Viz had a plan to use your evils and powers against you to destroy Earth."
"He had to look into your minds, hence giving you the idea of altered dreams."
"We even changed your clothes a few times to see if it affected your thoughts."
"So it was Viz all along with these plans."
"Where does you being a traitor come into the equation?"
"Death was the only thing that could separate you from your dream."
"Alterations to dreams can be detected by just about anyone."
"So I could only wake you up if I killed you in your dream."
"Afterall, death is the only thing that could wake any of you up."
Ohh. "I did not go unseen, however."
"It was only a matter of time before I was found out."
Oh.
"I went the full mile and altered the mind of Mr. Munch, your last dream teacher."
"I sat behind you and watched the execution to be sure everything went well."
"That is why you didn't see me when you went to the same room in Phred's dream."
"By that time, I was where I am standing now."
"The transmitter message you heard was a recording from another time."
"I transmitted it to you again when I knew you were about to wake up."
"I did it so you would know Viz's plans for you world."
"And now, he's taken Zack's freezing genes to power up a giant laser."
"Not long from now it will have charged enough to freeze the Earth."
"...I have only been trying to help you, so you could save your friends."
"Good job."
Oh... shit.
"Is the laser charging?"
"If nothing is done, your world will be solid ice."
"Not cool."
Okay... Hi Viz.
"Sorry Diz, the window view is reserved for the children."
Urge.
Okay... Oh, he has psychic powers, that's oddly convenient.
"I'm so sorry I ran out of cages to trap you and your friends in."
"You'll still enjoy the show, won't you?"
"Somehow I really doubt that."
"I'm sure it will be an unforgettable spectacle..."
"...Which is why I plan to watch it on my own ship without distractions."
Here's both my hands.
"Prepare yourself for the grand finale."
Okay bye.
So long.
I guess I'll just be here... by myself.
Thank you for the ship.
Okay.
I guess I'm here now... Well.
Alrighty then.
Ultra toothpaste.
Vanity area.
Screws, I can use those.
Ah shit.
Okay...
What goes in probably never comes out.
Well I just lost those screws but at least this'll come off.
Okay so...
Can I fish 'em out with this?
No?
Toothpaste?
Oh my God, why do I feel like I'm on a limited time when I'm definately not?
Okay, circle pattern, urr, committed to memory instantaneously.
Oh, I gotta do this again?
Oh God damn it.
Got that one.
Oh! This one's working differently than the other one, why didn't I notice that?
Oh! my God, it is different, holy shit.
Okay, got that one.
Okay, got that one, finally, Jesus Christ, this is harder than I thought it would be.
There we go, finally, holy shit that took forever!
Oh my God.
Okay.
What does this mean?
Is this really? Is that... Is that really it?
Oh, that's awfully convenient that the code was written exactly where that needed to be.
Now I have a key.
Ah, ther- Ooo, hello.
Ah, oh I'm upside down, hang on.
I'm upside down, so maybe that's supposed to be upside down.
I know how you work.
I know how you work, game.
Bam!
H'oh, look at me, I'm amazing.
I am amaz- Ooo, oo, oh.
Why was that necessary?
Oh a mug shot, that's hilarious, really.
You're hilarious.
You're so funny.
Ohhh...
Just let me try going over here now.
Need something to move it, maybe this as a crowbar?
Oh toothpaste. Bam, for some reason.
I don't know, oh man, it's gonna be a tough one, holy shit.
I got it!
Slather that thing.
Okay, so what's that gonna do for me? Get some laval?
Maybe combine this on the hook?
Ahh, dip it in the lava.
I'm so smart, I am so smart.
Lava java, okay.
Alright, whatever... I'm gonna ignore that pun for now, then I'm gonna burn the shit outta this.
There you go, that's how physics work.
Okay, I got a key for this.
Habadoinky.
Haboutalittleboiboiboink.
Ah hah...
...Okay.
Okay, so...
Now what?
Is whatever the hell it is open?
Ahhh... Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
So now I go to the ship wheel and then I'm done?
Hell yeah! Freeze that sucker.
Get 'em.
Get 'em, get 'em, get 'em...
Get 'em real good.
Freeze 'em.
Freeze 'em good.
Freeze 'em hard core.
He likes it, he's so hot.
Let's see him...
...Cool off for a bit.
"Soon this planet will be covered in a coat of ice."
"Yes."
Any minute now.
"Because evil-doers deserve a taste of their own evil!"
*Laughter*
It's a bit of self-punishment there.
Oh man, he said the thing that gonna get him to do the thing where he's gonna die.
Maybe not die, but just be froz- Ooo.
That's nice.
That's real nice there.
Oh geez, well... now he's dead.
That's a definite, that a... he's 100% dead.
Death is what happened to him and he is dead now.
"Amazing, you saved Earth and disposed of our wretched leader simultaneously."
"I managed to escape with this remote I found that used to be Viz's."
Awesome.
"Maybe I can use this remote to free your friends."
Aw thanks, dude.
"With all that's happened today, that's not a bad assumption."
"Well, give it a shot."
It's probably not gonna blow 'em all up.
Awww, he's okay...
Awww, she's okay...
Ohhh, he's probably okay...
"I'm pretty sure I know how to drive the ship we're in."
"You'll all be able to go back to your homes before you know it."
"...I'm not cold anymore..." "...This feels amazing!"
Ah, oh shit.
"I may have learned something from this experience."
"Friends really can come from anywhere."
Yeah... "Even space."
"all my life I've been devoted to doing as little as possible."
"Witnessing everything Phil has done helped me realise..."
"...Even a world as big as ours can be affected by what one person does."
"I guess I should say that I learned a lot from this experience."
"But really, only one lesson I learned today truly stands out to me."
"Stay in school."
Awww, that's a good life lesson to learn for everybody.
Stay in school, drink your milk and there you have it!
Riddle School is over.
That was quite a journey and this last one was
Pretty dang amazing, I gotta say, it was a lot longer than I thought it was gonna be
Which... Is not a bad thing and then again I got
stuck for a while there being stupid, but...
'Kay so that's not clickable.
But either way!
This was awesome! I had a lot of fun with this one
And to be perfectly honest, there are technically two more games after this series.
But I'm gonna spread 'em out a bit more I don't wanna just like...
Blast through the series as quickly as possible because it's really good.
And I really appreciate the work that went into it.
I mean apparently Riddle Transfer, which is the next in the series is...
Even bigger than this, and I have no idea;
I still have not seen any of the stuff so it's all completely new to me, but either way...
...Thank you guys so much for watching.
Thank you, JonBro who goes by Jonochrome now, officially.
It's what I knew him as before.
Thank you for making this game, and I can't wait to see what more cool things you make in the future
and what other cool stuff you're gonna be doing and what you've already done, so...
Thanks again everybody so much for watching...
I'm gonna hand around 'till the end of the credits just to make sure there's nothing else.
And then we're gonna get to the end.
So just hang on.
45 minutes!
Whoa, that's a long time.
So anyway, that is all for this, there's some special
Uh, features here that you can check out if you
beat the game; but it's all interesting to see how it all tied together.
So... Thank you everybody so much again for watching
and let me know what you thought in the comments down below.
And as always, I will see you...
...In the next video.
Ba-Bye! o/
'Kay, everything was dusty, that's what I did there.
You found my feather duster! Keep the change. Okay.
Thanks, I've been looking al-
Stop; Pro-dodging and basically being a badass that I am.